hi there Steve Kaufman here
Romanian how many of you would like to
learn Romanian why not it's an
interesting part of the world there's
perhaps 30 or more million people I
don't know the numbers in Romania and
Moldavia
it's Eastern Europe it's gypsy music
it's a lot of history you know the
Romanians were involved again I don't
know my Eastern European history well
enough in in they were involved in
Transylvania they were interacting with
the mud jars and the Slavs and the
Germans and stuff so it's interesting
but more than that we have a member at
link Michaela who's very active has
provided a lot of content for our
library a lot of lessons in Italian and
in Latin which he records he has helped
us a lot with our translation of our
interface into Italian a very keen
language learner speaks a lot of
languages I don't know how many and we
added new languages a while ago I got it
up to 20 and then we stopped because
it's it is work and we found the word
that many people's learning these new
languages like Finnish and Hebrew and
Esperanto and so forth Turkish so we
stopped but we said that if you can
generate enough support for a language
then we'll add it on and we said we
would require a thousand votes for a
language at the link page at Facebook
and if you were able to get a thousand
posts then we would add the language
Michaela it has managed to persuade over
500 people to vote for Romanian at the
link page there in Facebook and it's a
long you know road to get to a thousand
so I just thought that while we can't
bend the rules because we don't want to
change the rules that we've established
in terms of the number of votes required
I thought that I could help Michaela by
doing a little video to encourage you
both to learn Romanian and to vote for
Romanian at the link page on Facebook
and I will leave a link here so that you
can find it I don't know how to say
anything in Romanian not halal not
goodbye or anything else if we get
Romanian at Lake I will certainly study
it so thank you and time to start
learning Romanian or at least go to our
link page and help me kill it bye for
now